こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです。
と言うわけで、2015年最後の動画になります。
今年も応援してくださった皆様
毎回動画を楽しみにしてくださる皆様
いつもコメントしてくださる皆様
今年も本当にありがとうございました。
さぁ
今年のはじめしゃちょーは、いかがだったでしょうか。
総合的に見たとき
まぁ
オレの年
になったとまでは言いませんけども
なかなか大暴れできた年かなと思います。
今年最後の動画は
今年2015年の僕がつくった動画
全てではないんですけども
いろんな動画を、こう、なるべく
まとめてみた、ダイジェスト動画でございます。
いろいろ思い返してもらえればな、と思っております。
オレの今年は、こんなかんじでした。
【お年玉】１円玉１０００枚をブチ落とす
ビートボックスバトル【はじめvsダイチ】Beatbox Battle
【閲覧注意】乗り物酔いしないオレがイスで超回転した結果…
部屋で風船７００個膨らませてみた。　隙間男「山道を行く」
全員金髪ヤンキーで心霊スポット行ってみた
【バスケ】真夏の１on1　はじめしゃちょーvsJUNJUNプロ
金縛りに襲われました。助けてください。
【噂】かき氷のシロップは全部同じ味らしいよ…
滑らない靴vs床ローション
プリクラは何人まで撮れるのだろうか…
こっくりさん
【最終回】BIGチョコたちは結局１つになれたのか
巨大ムカデどっきり
【検証】黒マジックは日焼け止めとして有効なのか？！
世界最小？ポケットに入るドローン
森の中に超巨大カエルドッキリ
いろんな飲み物でカルピスを薄めてみた
大量のスポンジを装備して海を航海する
殺人事件ドッキリ２
落ちる！プール！やだ！はじめしゃちょーヒカキンで妖怪ウォッチ　ぷにぷに
生きる恐竜ロボット　PLEO
【恐怖】パラノーマル・グリーンスムージビリティ
室内で巨大ラジコンヘリを離陸させた結果
全身高速振動ベルトで最強エクササイズ
【実験】100袋の泡風呂入浴剤で超あわあわになれるのか
突然の爆発ドッキリ
【完結編】エクゾディアは1ターンで揃うのか？
【銃】はじめvsマホト
100輪車作ってみた
【実験】水を何リットル飲めば尿意がくるのか
はじめしゃちょー育成ゲームができましたwwwww
遊戯王カードの神、街に現る。
花粉症患者が大量の花粉を浴びるとこうなる
【頂上決戦】ビートボックスバトル　ヒカキンvsはじめ
BIGチョコ？オレがもっとBIGにしてやるぜ！
間違えてポテチ600袋買ってしまいました
宙に浮きながらピザを受け取ってみた
寝てる人を起こさずに電球でテニス
僕の家でできる限界レベルのジェンガ
大量のスマホ用スタンドを合体→全長6ｍ最強スタンド
【演技】ひとつのシーンを様々な表情でやってみた
じゃがりこ全種類混ぜてポテトサラダ作りたいでござる
帰ってきたらベイマックスがいるドッキリ
物凄いジャンプをするロボット…
風邪を切り裂く新兵器！！！怖い！！！
財布を無くしました。
自分に車輪を付けて乗り物になれるのか？
妖怪かぼちゃ人間、また現る！
はじめ、本格的に料理を作る。
【実験】ビー玉サーフィンやってみた
いろはすって7種類あるの、知ってたかい？
【涙の映画】Battle Of The Earth 5
全てを繋げる!最強の補修剤の実力とは
お肌が気になるのでドモホルンリンクル使ってみた
はじめしゃちょー、渋谷を制圧してみた
アルミホイルで鎧作ってお出掛けしてみた
スーパーボール350個を叩きつけるだけの動画
【実験】LINEスタンプ連打でiphoneはぶっ壊れるのか
大切な仲間
ジョイント式のフラフープを繋げて巨大フラフープを作る！
はじめしゃちょーの弟現る。子供の頃のはじめは…
部屋にダンボールで迷路作ってみた
【ギネス世界記録】740人でだるまさんがころんだやってみた
【なわとび】はじめは二重跳び何回できるのか
【騒音】目覚ましブブゼラ
謎の集団に追われてるんだけど！
ガリガリ君を潰s…混ぜて新たな味を作る！
と言うわけで
はじめしゃちょー2016年
2015年よりもさらに、
こう、過激に大胆に
ろっきゅんろーるにも、メチャクチャやっちゃうんで
ゆるーく、よろしくお願いします。
では、良いお年を。
じゃあな！